[Music]
Bonjour à tous Bienvenue Bienvenue
politican gray was the Google Cloud
submits Wow
oh no buddy I gotta bail peril is naboo
you exist yes
Sager my question implies you know on a
frame of the Mojave that was Audrey I
took Leakey Boogaloo Predacon gray
Julian's do demolish a tumultuous a
googly-eye madness Seto la mancha cougar
on top this kid when you google cloud
editor auntie Sunni revolution Obama's I
mean they're not from a seaman aircon
affair
is he a Perry the butler one Fat City
yeah handsome a disciplined L'Etoile
Santissima a cinematic attics the
paramatma on a vacant persona don't kiss
aell my place here the what Russia
Makana buckaroo ensemble proof software
shot we don't compare adekunle on that
all quite familiar knowledge on a donkey
Abu good that to lead the breakout
session given Wooper meadow degree on
feta sue confession Google Cloud
don't be Avenue messy messy
- look he on a particular the track news
road you know the company Murcia to no
patent era again monkey news no idea
Montecito be aa Co new shows on she
particularly am oh oh oh show Dewey
second our predecessor on post on
federal audience he's on the developer
you cannot vote on the jetty Marais
effects that I want you like Google
cloud dog allow me book would pass on
dinner Jeeves errababu could speaker Sam
Adams show 2d the person do not like it
here on crap erases Atelier in from cup
of category AHA low cloud mercy Google
Cloud and sorry Matt not a disease set
on the loop little fresh arugula a
commuter she Google Yahoo Johnson
presence P my dear auntie - PA yo
particular GT popular Kiev as many spots
vien even non-measurable new get a
L'Ouverture Donato a data center a
frankfurter
a song for bada air
padam kubernetes until Palmas Momo don't
Rita avec oops
all's pizookie goodness was au s-- v GM
of rajesh agree on fertility reveal
minutes not get revenge with con la vía
sergey mot google us a person here
Batsy set of hospital google a Khilafah
Gandia pollen a la la Rodion will be set
it's a been particular psycho she was a
second makes democracy no Scott fic
fantastic we one second is Nevada she
Google cast effect on comet evil meta
portal VA Rubio Ramirez on duty FME
Polly deep oceans in ASEAN whose mood
easier is it Sebastian
Babu good education to the cloud sad
Emma a Matt no mono da don't answer on
cone casino big Seop specific cloud if
you can I value cloud
mirapanis nyuk-nyuk of sankaranna fed
the workload do this on top risk is on
passes on a cloud donc c'est vrai to see
Daniels na on a VM to lift and shift on
a pass a on a basically workload
diseconomies don't like publication
Googler me
imagine skeeve especi don't was the
orders if they don't cat once it did not
do zones if they know psycho calm on the
machine only mock shave a passive look
louder in Madision shoes which the
parties enhancer calculated nom the next
reposition google assistive s passes key
Taunton super CC tab sumo and choir blah
da cunha don't have to bet she left her
structure give a permit the GG array on
Fed said to enormous transformation so
momentum kid not hack on it on hunting
well Robbie the gym shoes on fed a
comedian Kovac was a trooper watch
others data center a song for on a
location on continent was analyst a
dongju's a swab occur it is a nice dude
is a premium or extreme on quadrant Sam
Bianca new girl Pavano Kosciusko fat
extra mommy aesthetic eyes of a platform
and also not as Aparna Mayo citrus
accessible ax it was a way you see to
say technology
Hongki permit on fête du travail ignore
somebody from technology keeps her on
premises where the technology to cloud
the path of semi technology Google may
Matt not did wanna prove the pallium
Pope is devoid of additional said the
word strategy a commodity Chandra's
cheap case given aa difference if s cure
with the path of similar leader also
resolved mache on compunction a
strategic process et Google is Sally own
affair taught me el dorado mrs. Modi on
has any who the Euclid the Google cloud
on particular a makisi government would
even say we consider a local teenager on
the format is a keep with the energy
here the the court with a trace on a
voodoo so to conquer a case give a
vermin fella difference of cosa I think
in an illogical parrot a boost on Arriba
to make it have a user dick whatever
mode huh what are the lead engine Denis
only beyond remedy set on alderman set
upon a-naught marche can marshal a
telephony mobile the meal set she wants
a maxilla telephone immobile ax
heavy-duty aluminum due to unit is the
truth
prosecutor Anita Tuzla SWAT at the river
Nokia feature phone SWAT - blackberry
don't when the not work is person ballad
on Twitter
Kirsten the Polly the Polar Star not
believe it non-fatal nonprofit not solid
easily it was a villain illusion of etc
Co sumac she ate a complete form a
sous-vide Ursa a diesel terminate on the
melody set is open scale energy that
effort pescado melody set on LD be
declawed EPF work exact turkey Sunday
jollity modem in opus keys on
demariont'e on a sybian si vamos appear
on a Buddhist people sir may open stress
thermo presence amicus Kiva's passes on
it wha assign potions any rate it would
total modify on the ski surpasses your
solid hosting Daniel Denis
it wasn't the onions anyone a common
scene from cosmology I remote pond a
workload on premise element on cloud
measure ship esto cosas soir all
Rodriguez de Matos
Matt Tifft Lucas are upon doe Oh booth
one does not release the Geonosians is
not hopeless edge business the labels
why the description
hakuna of exercises executive don't buku
buku total eye transformation digital
india so to do business a dole
innovation keifa matron plays poha
epidemic capture a de novo key on pollen
seed investor visa policy de novo
patricia
dong says give aphromoo gideon fat Lexi
lissandra cloud of Abu cuprous parlay
the machine learning that allegiance
artificial the containerization doc
estación feathers a difference of a lot
more in front quad platform it is matp
is Odin agents artificial could use
sampler lift and shift on this tambien
on-premise Vedas amid McLeod it exists
Survey Monkey no motive
shake Google Cloud see that practice
interval technology it resonate more on
when reception fantastic on fed the
rapid is not release you know it would
be a party Chrissy this video any moi
is this converse a metal atom custody
with a mock him Abu coupons PA she
Google ciliary Larry Page is extremel
connect Eric's conversation Google cloud
on now if in Des Moines certain on the
repressive on material culture Xingu
gala in photo enemy upon poly manana uh
it has important seeker lovey
at Constantinople a class on Google
personally difference between two cities
in Sioux City
keno AC park issue say self isn't remote
on every future Electro's set a space
the principal give is idea on prepare a
not business the first Muhammad Ali
if you to draw have was a 10x thinking
in uber my ramen a fishy as Kiva the
rotation Z transform a not a news 3
Jana - Julian fed necessitated formula
an ensemble shot we the discussion
comparing from comedy group quinoa
schwanke try Google Cloud two new tools
deceitful Sebastian American OC
does a big bed to see Perry unfettered
life as no Ella possibility Google not
on sociated is a company but I don't
really lay off it lets you or mature /
defections sure
Lu Momentum's sure liberation declared a
epithets in the teaser Siskin valve was
Roger year none on summer swirl Nevada
keynote so and even on the breakout
session Jim ray avender the perceiver
what merci danke Jintao nucleon was on
vehicle because I see sits in front
closet a prima facie no on Hawaii vacant
on some of the difference and history a
live record with the reality also
slightest a second extra this not hope
reason effect isn't played data-driven
to money data-driven via suara me Apache
Cassandra Piske sheer volume Dhoni
extreme more important it is super job a
system operates in well technology doing
some puny involve what certain usually
occurs Romeo see province on Bovada
timoni extremity right so if we get more
mercy don't - no button Emilio mercy
specific issues get res important
Google as well a reputation that we not
were please grant oblique it's a regular
precalc username on the fitnah visa
small resna Papa Papa port a loony vous
like a needed service will keep having
the constant appraiser
it would learn federal Cuttino amount
the TOEFL technique above the de amigos
epic SEO develop Ivanova Padre
oh now see Betsy an ecosystem partner
yet observe more
primordial courses were the systemic
otter is not usually not a selkie news
ed a multi-site even more gooses were
the cabinet audit we can say couscous as
well see the petunia tecnológica don't
vote of acceptance at least don't you
see Betsy de restaurante up to now Ella
avec des entreprises Raquel booyakasha
jenkem a subpoena to Nevada laziness
rosamma where a donkey rest abou sweetie
Nixon on Johnny in Franco on a Rama
we were tragic city of exact year the
vomitus programa it's not visit on Juve
actually a loophole
speaker and switch into English - please
welcome will COO row thank you very much
[Music]
good morning everyone
it's great to be here in Paris city of
lights la ville lumiére when I was
getting ready to come here from New York
I wondered how Paris got that name so I
googled I found out two things the first
is did you know that in 1860s there were
56,000
gas lamps illuminating the streets and
boulevards of Paris the second why
reason is even more interesting Paris
got its name the city of lights because
of the role that it played in the 18th
century in the Age of Enlightenment so I
can't think of a better place to be to
be talking about the next set of
revolutions that will bring in a
different age of enlightenment the age
of innovation and digital transformation
now we're living in exciting times it's
a time of enormous change we're living
through a change in our lives in our
society and in business and all of this
is happening at an unprecedented pace
now one of the places that we can see
this change is in the fortune 500 the
fortune 500 was first set up in 1955
with an initial set of 500 companies
only 60 years later in 2014 only 61 of
those companies remain now if you are
one of the 439 that is a pretty scary
statistic and from that very first 500
companies nobody remembers unless you're
a car enthusiast the American car maker
Studebaker but we have welcomed Tesla
we don't remember Collins radio but
Netflix is here companies are going out
of business companies are being acquired
and new companies are coming in and it's
happening faster and faster every day so
what is driving all this change what's
happening what is the difference between
organizations that fail and those that
thrive and of course the answer is
technology technologies everywhere
and this intersection of various
technology trends cloud and mobile and
social and IOT and big data and machine
learning are having a profound impact in
our lives and are in our businesses
now before I came to Google I had a
pretty long career in financial services
and we had a we had a very simple
mission you know we were building
systems to enable efficient frictionless
safe and sound financial markets
unfortunately though doing that meant we
had to spend an inordinate amount of
time on things like hardware procurement
and supply chain management and network
setup and databases and software
upgrades now cloud enables you to change
that it enables you to focus on
technology that differentiates your
business and defocus technology that
does not and it doesn't end with cloud
with now with mobile and social
businesses can reach their customers no
matter where they are on the planet and
it's not just people devices as well
with IOT Internet of Things and all
these interactions are now creating data
that can be processed with big data and
machine learning to turn into insights
and engagement models with our customers
that we were never able to do before and
this is available to everyone no matter
how large or how small
so it is no longer about big versus
small now it's about the fast versus the
slow companies need to be faster they
need to be faster identifying customer
trends and they need to be faster at
responding to market they need to be
faster at decision-making they need to
be faster at everything change is going
to come the question is are you going to
be an agent of it or are you going to be
a casualty now the way to deal with that
change is of course again through
technology at Google we believe that
every company regardless of its size or
industry will differentiate themselves
through technology and all of that is
centered on data so we believe that
every company is or will become a
technology company and in this world
your engineering talent is your only
sustainable advantage so I've been a New
Yorker for 20 years but I'm originally
from Turkey when I was growing up in
Turkey you're on the quality of your
public transportation kind of depended
on your proximity to your fellow
passengers so if you didn't have money
you know buses were super cheap but man
they were packed like sardines and if
you had a little bit more money you
could get a cab where you could have the
whole car to yourself except now you
were at the mercy of your driver and I
am convinced that every single driver in
Turkey thinks they're a Formula One
driver except you know the safety and
the security and in between these two
things we had what we call the Dornish
the literal translation of that word
means stopped it means stuffed so these
are smaller cars usually like sedans or
minivans and they don't have fixed stops
but they have fixed routes and if you
want to get on one you hail wine and
they stop and if they have room to stuff
one person in another person in you get
in
so because it's a smaller
Carr they're limited by how many people
they can stuff by the number of their
seats so it's only marginally you know
more expensive than the bus but it is
kind of much better than much better
than the experience is much better than
the bus so that was ride-sharing one not
zero the Turkish way now today we're
sharing we were experiencing ride
sharing to dato the Global Way
ride-sharing companies are completely
transforming the transportation industry
all over the world they are using
technology to completely undermine the
principles or the assumptions that the
previous business model was predicated
upon and it's not just the app that
allows you to Hale the car and then know
where the car is and the driver finds
you it's also things like you know
availability of the GPS and maps and
voice which means that the driver
doesn't have to memorize every road and
every point of interest that everybody
might want to know and it's about being
able to give feedback so that you can
get a sense of the credibility of the
driver so you're not at the at the mercy
or the Formula One drivers in Istanbul
and so this is all has changed
completely how transfer me
transportation works and it doesn't mean
that uber or lyft will be the winners it
just means that that industry has been
completely changed and it will never be
the same again and most likely the next
set of disruption in that industry is
going to be the self-driving cars where
you won't even need that cab driver this
is what we call digital transformation
and it's not doing things just a little
bit better it is doing things
differently it is about doing different
things now the question that you should
be asking here today is what does your
digital transformation look like what is
that journey like for you and and that
journey is not to the clouds cloud is
not a destination
is a vehicle that gets you to your
digital transformation now as you ask
that question there are four things that
you need to think about the first is
optimization how do you optimize your IT
operations how do you get out of the
business of delivering technology that
doesn't differentiate your business now
we say make it our problem because you
know what delivering infrastructure
infrastructure and platforms at extreme
scale with great reliability and
performance and with trust and security
is what we do best here at Google
second is um collaboration how do we
help you create an environment in your
own shops that that promotes innovation
and how do we create an environment
where the some is greater than the the
pole is greater than some of the pieces
and it's not just about making things a
little bit faster and a little bit
better it's about doing things
differently it's about doing different
things then we're going to talk about
acceleration how can we help your
business help you accelerate your
business with data and machine learning
and finally we're gonna talk about
partnering because that journey to your
digital transformation doesn't have to
be one that you walk alone that
partnership starts with openness for us
and it's more than just open source it's
about flexible architectures and
flexible and - customer friendly costing
structures now we how can we take
everything that makes Google great and
share that with you and go beyond that
how do we co invest in the success of
your business with you
we'll talk about that and at Google it
is not about just infrastructure it's
about the collaboration platforms it's
about being able to run your
applications safe and securely and it's
about data and analytics and it's about
machine learning
so during the course of today's
presentations we are going to share with
you our thoughts on what that digital
transformation journey looks like and
the various way stations in it so let's
start with optimization well
congratulations you have made the
decision to move to the cloud you've
made the decision to adopt a technology
platform that enables you to focus on
what's important for your business to be
more efficient to collaborate better to
innovate faster be more agile be more
responsive now how do you pick your
cloud provider what factors help you
determine who is going to be the best
partner in that digital transformation
now in my role I get to talk to a lot of
c-level executives and IT professionals
like you and here is what they told me
here is what you told me you said it's
about reliability it's about security
excellent support performance and cost
effectiveness in that order you picked
these because cloud infrastructure is
not a commodity because the quality of
the infrastructure that you are going to
build your business on matters it makes
a big difference and these are the
things that actually differentiates us
at Google our ability to run at Planet
scale with great reliability and
performance with trust and security with
excellent partnership and good price we
have been building and operating a
planet-scale cloud for a very long time
now over the years we've built seven
platforms with over 1 billion users each
anyone recognize those logos raise your
hand if you have used any of these
products for me raise your hand all
right raise your hand all right keep
your hand up if you use them today yeah
and keep your hand up if you've used
them since I started
talking alright I appreciate the honesty
thank you for being customers but as we
did that along the way we learned quite
a bit about running a cloud at scale and
you know we learned about security and
reliability and efficiency and you know
all the all the experiences that you
enjoy about Google already and it is
that same infrastructure and expertise
that we now offer to our GCP clients so
they can run their businesses at scale
where the reliability and security and
now today are GCP clients are serving
there over 1 billion users on GCP
alright so how does Google build
reliable systems how do we do it it's
not just one thing it's many things it's
about how we do datacenter is it's how
we think about networking it's about you
know how we build and deploy software we
build um s-sorry our site reliability
engineering practice years ago to be
able to run ultra scalable and reliable
systems and our engineers over time have
come up with new paradigms on how to run
these large systems and they became with
new ways of introducing change at high
velocity without compromising from
reliability or performance so we
literally did write the book on it no we
took all our experiences and we put it
together and we published it on our
website and it's free and available for
everyone and it is that same experience
that we are now offering our customers
with our customer reliably engineering
practice where we take our experiences
our MOPP methods and our frameworks and
now we share them with you
what's better than reliability its
reliability that doesn't come with a
high price tag indeed for dollar for
dollar GCP provides better performance
value than any other cloud provider in
the market this is from cloud spectators
independent benchmarking study that was
published earlier
this summer in a key part of delivering
that performance is our global premium
network we run and operate the world's
largest IP data network we have dark and
light fibre across every continent on
the planet except for Antarctica
we have undersea cables across the
Atlantic and the Pacific and our data
centers don't connect to just each other
like some competing clouds to our data
centers connect to every single ISP in
the world today about 40% of the world's
entire Internet traffic goes through our
network and we recently introduced a
premium network in addition to our
already super ultra-fast standard
Network if you need it it's about 70
percent more performant now we pay
incredible amount of attention to the
quality and the reach of our network why
do we do that we do that because if you
are a business with customers all over
the planet their performance and your
reliability of that network is going to
be important to you the other reason we
do this is for security remember we
talked about the five factors at the
beginning that was important you know
security was number two the reality is
the fewer public internet chance at
points you have in your network the less
likely are you going to get cyber
attacks because you'll be eliminating
things like men in the middle traffic
profiling and shaping and surveillance a
network you control and ten is
inherently safer at Google our ability
to deliver security at scale is what
differentiates us now used to be that
security was the reason people didn't
move to the cloud today security is the
reason to move to the cloud we believe
in the fence and that's that means that
we embed security at every layer of
our stock we custom design and build our
servers and networking equipment we
eliminate any unnecessary parts that
would create additional vulnerabilities
we've run proprietary and hardened
operating systems and we run software
stocks that we constantly test and fix
for vulnerabilities now above all of
this we believe in a very simple
philosophy we trust nothing we believe
that if anything can fail or can be
compromised it will fail and it will get
compromised how far do we take this
philosophy let me introduce you to Titan
Titan is a custom chip designed by
Google we put it on all our new servers
and hardware into network cards and our
devices it allows us to protect the
identity of our machines by establishing
a hardware way to trust it helps us
identify the hardware and protects
against tampering at the hardware BIOS
and services level now in Greek
mythology Titans were these big giants
of incredible strength
well Titan packs all of that in this
tiny little chip the titan chip that you
see up there is smaller than my
fingernail on my pinky now if you are in
the audience today and you're in one of
the regulated industries you're in
financial services or you're in
healthcare or in other industry you're
saying oh this is great it's awesome but
how about compliance how can Google help
us with that but it is very important to
us to help our clients be able to use
our systems and sources no matter which
industry or geography they set on so
every year we go through dozens and
dozens of independent verifications of
our security privacy and compliance
controls some examples of them are
appear on the screen like our Sauk and
ISO certifications our PCI compliance
and and privacy shield now in addition
to these global certifications we also
provide local certifications in
individual countries as I said we're
committed to helping our customers meet
their regulatory and policy demands no
matter where they are another example of
this is the upcoming European global
data protection regulation gdpr and we
are fully committed to be complying with
it by the time it goes into effect May
of 2018
we are constantly innovating in our
quest to find better ways to help you
secure your business so today I'm going
to highlight two the first one is
identity aware proxy remember how I said
we don't trust anything one of the
things we don't trust is corporate
networks and VPNs now traditional
security relies on VPNs and firewalls
now the problem with that if once a bad
actor gets in they can do a lot of
damage so instead we offer identity
aware proxy which enables you to enforce
who gets access to what at the
application layer not where the remote
access VPN and firewalls the second one
I want to highlight today is our data
loss prevention API later loss
prevention API lets you discover PII and
other sensitive data and give you an
option to be able to redact or anonymize
it now to show us some of this
innovation in action I'd like to call
out France s convoy to show us the power
of DLP API
now super cool cool intro to the moment
uh women okay just do the example the
cuckoo's connect on Atkins Fisher let
data loss prevention API to the ball
which is basically a utility slack
simulation epithelia system to chat
Leapster m-x conv fell over till easy
that's it slack pas vrai they are say
Louvre slack
SEPA icon folder in first conversation a
panel Sitka doesn't fit on any keep -
women kitten hundred see the fellow on
dubbing the previous one player yep a
post post Isola sunken the battleship
and on for ya impetus hit información
que yo don't buy example on a view to
toe debut in cactuses at the security
station American schedule a cougar
country the Minnesota Jeannie Sega
showed the treason portal for Jamaica
she's the power salami on Mississippi on
photo missus and the commode she
identified a son-in-law a confuted easy
don't sir sabia packin on our C pesetas
animation computer powwow don't pack
some planet in a telephone or noddy's
email on a Ducati on add a photo take a
trip a script papa mm the tell me the
Correa Tucson fit Saavik contra name not
hope no political diversity
don't see unless a second gaseous film
together
oh no I am column on selenium violation
official politic the vivacity skip off
I'm legal don't unfit Houston it in his
own lab data loss prevention API a
skills used today this Appel test long
susi sudah son if you own a vac they
deliver a pro/con screen of the but so
slack connect hey Super T but you know
pyramid affair DLP clean can execute
up-to-date Arctic is some consider a
in accept a blog pan no politics no
political security Vaughn disparate
don't can fit on a few key add 24
- Sandeep are you okay ona OC only way
they got to agree on a level is email me
back on on a garden or catalysis the
secretory cell Pascal said LA City da no
political don't sad Sigrid cashews
connect on-screen and fit on say I don't
usually say yeah the emphasis on retreat
under a limited music memory and tweet
so France asked voila a mono honor in
the same party la demo they just pour
Mon kicker to see me back just like
flaxseed cambium a civil across South
Africa shows servo platformer movie she
loved her don't pursue that an icon
Swiss sit pretty pass web saying camera
its estimate what Mike said for the way
a I'm perfectly a planner shows
completely donk on valium that he'll
trade a Catholic today of filtrate the
permit con via the visage ferocious
tragedy of the DoCoMo
party don't care example of Hans with a
passport holder chemo don't you point
photo a via excuse Anna she all we fee
at all but over all the test unlocks on
a ship vascular we feel enough clear may
unfit posit
posted photos soon a nationally body to
test on Vasco and fit or Akane pass from
Oakland Museum vaccine evil any bank a
totally valid low don't comfort we see
the fell refresh say oops
vara Dan fit on a panel Eevee best QC
panini order captivate the Vallabh Park
hoon chinchilla key exactly monument may
have economy differ Allah though subpar
constantly motive the catalytic ever
habla yep Alessandria don't publish on
the phone photo Ebola Manoa see on
eleven
a proofing in showbiz on the coup for
latina $30 della demo move on quicker
some enough paths in moeshouden Okemo so
naturally Doki Molly fits on top see
this selfie no no I'm coming for oh I
don't see the visage generally visa
seems ready mo way voila yeah see thank
Frank for that wonderful demo no the LP
is just one of the examples of how we
help you secure your businesses now our
security capabilities don't just end
with infrastructure they go into our
collaboration platforms and extend all
the way up to our endpoints and access
platforms our global scale access across
the enterprise and our consumer gives us
unprecedented visibility to threats so
it may give you an example in Gmail over
1 billion users that we have in Gmail
every minute we filter out 10 million
spam messages and we are able to do that
with 99% accuracy thanks to our machine
learning models for a chrome users we
warned them of of suspected malware 992
times a minutes and we notify them of
potentially unwanted software 6000 times
for our Android users we check the
health of 400 million devices daily and
for 6 billion mobile apps we check them
to make sure they're not infected we
protect 2 billion mobile phones tablets
and other devices that use Google Safe
Browsing technology for their our GCP
clients this means and
and security all the way from
infrastructure to endpoints and access
platforms now infrastructure provides
the foundation of your business and with
the right cloud partner you can optimize
your infrastructure and make it more
reliable more secure and most connected
now once you've done that we can help
you accelerate that path to innovation
and to continue the discussion into
about this new age of enlightenment the
age of innovation and transformation I
would love to call on stage one of my
collaborators they would back her to
talk about collaboration welcome on
stage Thank You oku for the introduction
good morning Bonjour it's great to be in
Paris thank you for coming today
my name is David Thacker I'm a vice
president of product management at
Google I'm responsible for our G suite
products and I'm based in our Silicon
Valley headquarters in California today
I'm going to talk about G suite and how
it can transform the way your company
works making it much more collaboration
collaborative so when we think about the
world and we think about the major
achievements and whether it's business
or architecture engineering
collaborations always been a central
part of that so I was looking today for
an example of the highlight that's
relevant to France and to Paris so I
want to talk about the Eiffel Tower and
the collaboration that went into making
the structure I think a lot of people
believe such as myself I had thought
that Gustave Eiffel was a genius that
designed and created the Eiffel Tower
himself but when you study the history
it's actually much more complex the
Eiffel Tower the original sketch that
you see behind me was developed by two
structural engineers working together in
fact this sketch was developed by one of
them while he was working at home so the
next time your boss tells you you can't
work from home just remind them that
sometimes your most creative elements
come out when you're working at home
away from the office they brought this
sketch into their office and they
reviewed it with a few other people
including their head of architecture the
head of architecture at their firm said
this is a great structure but we need to
make it my
better and so he added his his insight
and as a result they developed some
other embellishments such as the
decorative arches you see at the bottom
the Eiffel Tower or the glass
Observatory that you see on the first
floor they then took this to Gustav
Eiffel who acquired the patent and with
a team of 300 people came up with the
final designs and constructed the
building over the course of two years
the final achievement was a tallest
man-made structure in the world at the
time in 1889 and we'd certainly today
think of it as a masterpiece now
although that was 130 years ago when you
think about the world of business today
in the year 2017 whether your business
is creating life-saving medicines or
running a global shipping company or
advancing telecommunications creating
electric cars all these achievements
would not be possible without the
collaborative efforts of your employees
working together and employees today
want the best tools to work together so
they can work more quickly so they can
be more productive and so they can focus
on maximizing their creative output in
fact employees that have the best tools
are happier overall and so that's really
why we created G sweet Jesus wheat is
our collection of products to maximize
the company's creative output to make
employees more collaborative now when
creating G sweet our productivity
solution we took the best of our
consumer products the ease of use the
intuitive design the scalability the
intelligence built into the products and
we combine that with a world-class set
of enterprise features around
scalability performance
cost-effectiveness and together we've
created a very compelling solution for
companies but before I talk about the
product I first want to talk about some
research we do and this statistic 5% so
we did a lot of internal research and
external research at Google user studies
look at the modern office worker the
modern professional to see how they
spend their time and the results were
pretty shocking
so the typical modern offers office
place worker today spends only five
percent of their time on creative work
and strategic work the other 95 percent
of their time is spent on more mundane
activities that get in the way of this
other work this can include searching
for files and searching for information
trying to find the right person your
company to get a hold of to get the
right answer to a question it can
involve things like trying to set up a
meeting to get people together in the
same room or even trying to join an
audio conference in video conferencing
meeting and worrying about codes there
are lots of small things that get in the
way of the average employees typical
workday here's another example and a lot
of companies today the way that
companies collaborate around documents
whether they're creating a slide or
presentation a team may have many
individuals all with numerous files on
their desktop for the same file slightly
different versions emailing large
attachments back and forth trying to
stay on the same page with the end
result of trying to create that final
final version that they can present this
isn't a great way of working and it's
not very efficient when you look at how
a G Suite customer operates
collaboration is central in Google Docs
one of our most popular features today
and we launched this ten years ago is
the ability to collaborate in real time
so you can have a set of multiple
editors and authors all working on a
document whether it's from their laptop
or whether it's from their mobile device
they can edit in real time and they can
see the changes as they happen if they
have comments if they have questions
this can all be addressed in real time
making the process much much faster we
pioneered this and we've continued to
extend this collaboration throughout our
products another example is our team
drive feature which we launched earlier
this year so drive is our cloud-based
storage solution and we created the
concept of a team so now in Drive you
can set up a folder or a shared
workspace for your team where you can
store all the files and information
related to that team so now every member
of your team always has access to the
latest files they can collaborate in all
these files in real time it doesn't
matter whether they're on the go or
where they're in the office they have
access to this data we've combined this
with our enterprise feature set such
that Google vault for ediscovery and
compliance and there's some great
security features built in because the
files belong to the team
if a member leaves a team or someone
leaves the company a team member leaves
the company you can revoke access to
these files but all the files stay on
with the team so the rest of the
employees that are left behind on the
team can continue working at the same
pace another example of collaboration in
G suite is our Hangouts meet video
conferencing solution video conferencing
is integrated seamlessly into into G
suite so it's very easy to set up a
meeting that has video conferencing
support and whether an employee wants to
judge to join from their mobile device
whether they want to join from a laptop
or whether they're in a meeting room
with access to video conferencing
hardware with one click they're
seamlessly added to the meeting now
Google we see a big trend where the
future of meetings is video conference
moving away from audio conference and
there's been some academic research
that's looked at audio conferences in
the workplace environment and they found
that people that join in are simply
participating via phone are a lot less
engaged in the meeting they're much more
likely to be multitasking and they're a
lot less likely to participate with
video conferencing that changes
dramatically people are more engaged
humans have a natural instinct to want
to work face-to-face with individuals so
it doesn't matter whether you're in
different time zones or different
audiences offices you can seamlessly
collaborate through video conferencing
and that's collaboration I now want to
in turn your attention to machine
learning artificial intelligence and how
that can impact the productivity suite
so at Google we have a huge focus on
machine learning and Nai and building
that into our products we want to create
magical product experiences throughout G
suite our focus is to automate and let
machines take care of the mundane and
the mindless tasks and let humans really
focus on that creative work so we want
to automate this 95 percent of stuff
that gets in the way of employees doing
their best work I'm going to show you
some examples of how that works
throughout the products but Google is
uniquely positioned to focus on AI due
to our infrastructure which you heard
about earlier today we have a
world-class set of data scientists and
machine learning experts at Google and
finally we have a massive
data that we can use to train our models
so let's see how machine learning works
in the product 'day a simple example is
dr quick access so in our dry product
when someone comes in their product for
the first time or they're typically
looking to find a file and it used to be
you'd have to search to find that file
well we created this feature quick
access where now when you when you come
into drive you'll see a set of five
suggested files these are files we
predict you may want to open and we look
at a variety of different signals we
look at the time of day it is we look at
what meeting you are in based on what's
on your calendar we look at who you've
been collaborating with recently on
email or instant messaging and using all
these various signals our models will
predict which file you want to open
now this saves users a lot of time it's
very accurate over 40 percent of our
file stay and Driver open through this
quick access feature and that number
keeps going up as our models get better
and better so a user on a mobile device
that's trying to find that file quickly
can find it right away and with one
click start viewing it really powerful
another example of machine learning our
products is the Gmail smart reply
features some of you may have seen this
before but now in Gmail on your mobile
device when you receive an incoming
email we'll use artificial intelligence
to suggest three possible responses for
you for that email our studies show that
a lot of email communication today is
short form in nature and can be
addressed with such a solution so in
this example you see behind me a
colleague of mine has emailed me and
asked me if I've looked at the latest
thought blog files to analyze them with
one click I can say yes I'm working on
it and get back to them again these are
small things but they add up over the
course of the day and could save users a
lot of time especially in that mobile
use case when you're on the go and it's
much more difficult to type an answer
and this model gets better and better as
we have more data and more usage of the
product the third example I want to give
today is for our sheets product which is
our cloud-based spreadsheet solution we
launched a feature last year called
exploring sheets now spreadsheets are
the most common way employees in your
enterprise will access data
and our studies have found that a third
of your employees aren't familiar with
formulas or don't really know how to use
formulas and spreadsheets so it's very
difficult for them to get insights into
the data so with our explore feature we
made it easy for anyone to get data and
insights from their spreadsheet and the
way we do that is through natural
language processing where a user can
simply ask questions of the data and
we'll show them the answers so rather
than explain this I think the best way
is to see it so I'd like to invite my
colleague Robert cubist on stage to give
you a demonstration of this feature
Robert thank you David
moonroof for nail polish apart from say
so I will switch to English as well I
assume everybody has seen one of those a
spreadsheet in one form of the or the
other and temperature tablet tables are
really really powerful form it to
structure your data now so it sound may
be a little scary but it's no surprise
to you that most companies are actually
relying on these kinds of data but only
as David mentioned already only about 30
percent feel comfortable to get insights
out of their spreadsheet by using
formulas charts and things like that so
to enable more users to get insights
actions and charts out of their
spreadsheets we enabled the Explorer
re-edit the Explorer button to sheets so
when I click here some metrics happen
behind the scenes and we give you some
actions in the insights on the right
side as you can see here so we can see
for instance for every increase of 100
euro in revenue our profit increases by
sixty eight point five years so that's
pretty nice as you can see the stretch
spreadsheet is about dessert sales so
let's see if we can find a nice heart
I think the pie chart here is probably
pretty appropriate for for desserts so
what we can do is we can just with one
click at this chart into our spreadsheet
now imagine what you would have to do if
you would have to go to the menu select
the chart find the appropriate chart
select the columns that you want to
display in this Furth
so you can see that this
just saved you a whole lot of time now
if you don't find the answer that you're
looking for you can actually use natural
language processing to see like what
what data is in my spreadsheet so what I
want to see here is I want to look for
the top items sold in in fat and as you
can see here we have some answers it
gives us also a formula and I'm not the
most proficient in sheets but I probably
could could have figured this formula
out with like my favorite search engine
and looking how I can find like and do
this calculation but it would have taken
me quite some time again and probably
some errors along the way so here you
just type in your question and you get
the formula presented to you and can use
it now let's look at something else I'm
gonna see who are the best sales ops so
we are also tracking the sales for up
here so or sales rep and fab and as you
can see here Benjamin Button is the best
sales rep and fab and I can treat this
very quickly and say in March and see
like Mary Tyler Moore is coming up very
very quickly so Benjamin should watch
this back
so with Explorer we edit for users to
get insights out of their data very
easily and using natural language
processing and machine learning to do
that with that thank you very much back
to David
[Applause]
thanks Robert so that's one of the
coolest features in G suite today that's
a great example of artificial
intelligence and we're really just
getting started with these features
again we want to help companies maximize
their creative output right so we want
to democratize access to data and this
is an important stepping stone stone in
that so let's talk about customers and
how they're realizing value from this so
PwC which is a large global client
services firm migrated to G suite over
the last couple years after they had
migrated to G Suites they ran an
internal study to look at where their
employees actually saving more time and
what they found in these results is that
the average employee with saving 9 hours
per week due to some of these
time-saving features in G suite and
collaborative G Suites that's a lot of
time savings when you think about 9
hours over the course of the entire
employee base that adds up that's more
time to focus on higher value activities
such as serving and advising clients
it's really a powerful game changer so
next let's talk about how we've made G
suite more extensible so in G suite we
make it very easy to plug in your own
internal workflow or third-party
applications or data we have a set of
tools called app maker Apps Script and a
set of api's that allow anyone in your
company to easily create applications on
top of G suite leveraging GG sweeeeet
data leveraging third-party data and
making it easy to integrate workflow
into the G suite experience an example
of this is the Gmail add-on framework
which we had announced earlier this year
this lets you create an application that
can plug into Gmail so you can think of
a lot of situations where for your
employees you want to make it easy on
their workflow such as a sales person
having access to their CRM data plugged
into G suite right when they're sending
emails to clients and prospects we're
gonna continue to invest in this to make
it very easy we want to think of G suite
as a platform that you can build your
business on top of and finally I want to
talk about some of the administrative
controls in G suite so G Suites we have
a set of administrator features to make
you be able to optimize G suite for your
enterprise deployment
everything from data loss prevention to
mobile device management we'd make the
admin controls very simple and intuitive
to use so that concludes my presentation
on G suite I hope that gives you an idea
of how it can transform the way a
company works helping you focus on
collaboration helping your employees be
more productive and helping them
maximize their creative output earlier
today you heard us talk about optimizing
your infrastructure and security I just
spoke about collaboration and how that
can change your company's work culture
next we're gonna talk about accelerate
we want to talk and that my colleague
Brad caller is gonna come on stage and
talk to you about how you can accelerate
your business by focusing on what your
new uniquely suited for Brad
[Music]
thanks David and now I want to talk to
you about another reason for using
Google cloud which is to have a partner
that helps you manage your data and
drive intelligence from your data better
than any other cloud you want to help
accelerate your business to allow you to
create software faster operate faster
and find new insights and opportunities
faster than ever before and given the
vast amount of data that's being
generated every day it's a challenge to
extract meaning from data and it's even
harder to make critical decisions using
it you shouldn't have to worry about how
to configure your databases or have you
you know correctly set up your indexes
for efficient queries or how to manage
your infrastructure in general instead
you should like Google Cloud take care
of those issues and take care of the
infrastructure while you instead focus
on finding new insights to drive your
business and nowhere does Google's
innovation show up more sharply than in
art technology for managing and using
your data both for creating applications
and for driving insights and we make
this available to you through Google
clouds and the end integrated manage
analytics platform over the last year
we've been building out our platforms
capabilities and our platform now ranges
from storage to data warehousing
ingestion PII cleaning
ETL batch and streaming data pipelines
visualization and machine learning and
it's extended by an ecosystem of
partners including tableau lucre
informatica talon and many more advanced
data and analytics leading companies now
the first thing you need in order to
manage your data is a scalable and
available database but databases have
always had a fundamental limitation you
either had to pick a relational database
that has nice relational strong
consistency semantics
but you had a sacrifice scalability or
you could pick a no signal database that
scales out horizontally but you have a
sacrifice consistency and that creates a
significant pain and burden for your
developers and we've set out to solve
that fundamental problem with our
database service cloud spanner cloud
spanner is the first and only relational
database that scales outs horizontally
providing strong consistency at scale it
scales horizontally like a no sequel
database so it can handle pretty much
any transaction alone while still
providing the same sequel semantics and
relational capabilities and strong
consistency of a traditional database
and as an extra bonus spanner can be
globally distributed without sacrificing
consistency performance performance or
availability and on top of that it's a
fully managed service so it's trivial to
administer and it's battle-tested
we use spanner for hundreds of critical
applications inside of Google including
Adwords and now I'd like to turn it over
to Robert who will give us a look at
cloud spanner in action Robert
[Applause]
[Music]
all right hello everyone again
so Esprit just mentioned cloud spanner
combines the reliability the ease of use
of an SQL database with the horizontal
scalability of a new SQL database but
let me show you in in real on action now
let's start at the beginning at creating
a database if you want to create a
highly scalable and available database
which is set up for failover you need
like replication and charting and things
like that and it's quite a complex task
that involves a lot of configuration
even third party things like that now
even if you use a managed database
service like setting this up for
failover and high availability it can be
quite complex
now with cloud spanner we put all this
into one screen as you can see here I
just named the instance I choose the
configuration in my case I want to have
your west regional instance I say how
many notes I'm gonna have I want to have
10 notes here and I click create and
within seconds I have a database at my
disposal
now what happens behind the scene is
that we separate compute and storage and
with this VN able cloud spanner to scale
horizontally but also we set it up for
high availability and disaster recovery
but let me show you a little bit more
real example now what I have here is a
ticket pro core application now imagine
you are an event organiser and you want
to sell tickets and you have a platform
where you basically make this tickets
available you can imagine this that it's
really important that I want to sell
each ticket I don't want to sell a
ticket twice and even worse I don't want
to charge any customer twice now for
this it's obvious that we need like a
transactional system and if this poker
if this platform is locally then I need
something that is locally distributed
now to show you that this is just like a
relational database here is Sistema for
this ticket application that you just
so so I have a bunch of tables that can
be connected and joined together you see
columns in these tables that are
strongly typed even some of these tables
are actually pretty large so the ticket
tables has almost two billion rows but
there's no edit like complexity from no
SQL system right so what you see here is
what you basically are familiar with if
you have worked with a traditional
relational database system now while all
this is running I can still run some
queries against this database so in this
query here I'll just look at all the
events that are happening tonight all
over the world and how many seats are
still available for these events
now again what you don't see in here is
any edit complex ability now this query
that you see there it's just the
standard SQL query with some addition
for spinner now we understand that your
business changes and your application
develop and what you don't want to have
is that your business comes to a
grinding halt if you need to change that
they add the schema for instance now
with cloud spanner you have a
transactional consistent
capability to do online schema changes
so while all your workload is happening
you can change your schema and if your
app grows if you become really popular
you want to add some capacity now again
with a traditional database system if
you won't need to scale up vertically
you need to procure a new machine you
need to basically foil it failover to
new to your new hardware which usually
occurs some downtime or if you have a
scale out system you have the oldest
complexity that I talked about in the
beginning
now if cloudspinner again we put all
this into one screen so I go to edit
instance I choose a new number of notes
42 in this case because this is always
the right answer and I click Save and
within seconds I have this new capacity
at my disposal now let's just recap
with cloudspinner you get a highly
reliable performant and fully managed
database that can be multi-regional with
this five nines of availability you can
have it synchronously globally
replicated and you get all this
interoperability that you know from SQL
and asset transactions with advanced
features like versioning online schema
changes and strong consistency so please
try cloud spanner and I hope you enjoyed
the demo thanks right thanks thanks
Robert for that great demo now in terms
of using data we see our customers
breaking down data silos with the goal
of becoming a data-driven company they
want to make it faster and easier for
their employees to mine data for
insights and one of the most important
services to achieve that is bigquery
bigquery is the data while warehouse
providing fast interactive analysis of
data sets those data sets can range from
terabytes to petabytes and you get your
results in seconds to minutes instead of
hours to days it allows you to quickly
find insights over virtually any amount
of data it uses sequel it's encrypted
durable highly available in its scale
and speed are simply amazing
now we're seeing our customers use our
analytics products in all sorts of ways
but there are three primary use cases
the first is migrating your data
warehouse to bigquery we've seen
hundreds of companies make the move to
bigquery in industries ranging from
manufacturing to media to finance and
healthcare and second we're seeing
customers that needed help in reducing
the cost and complexity of running
Hadoop and spark clusters so to address
this we provide a data proc service that
provides fully managed to dupe and spark
clusters to easily run your workloads so
this is a great way of reducing the cost
and hassle of running Hadoop and spark
yourself
in the third use cases we're seeing
customers that combined together pub/sub
plus data flow plus bigquery together to
analyzing streaming datasets in real
time for applications such as data
mining personalized advertising and
building industrial IOT systems so as
you can see we're unlocking the power of
your data with end-to-end integrated
managed analytics so you can focus on
finding those insights to drive your
business now interactive analysis is a
great starting point but to fully take
advantage of that sea of data you have a
company needs to leverage AI and we've
been making huge investments in machine
learning so that every Google cloud
customer has an on-ramp into AI and we
let you take advantage of artificial
intelligence in two ways first we're
taking the investment in AI that Google
is already doing for its own products
like photos translate and other products
and making those available to you via
very simple to use ap eyes so you don't
have to know anything about artificial
intelligence to start adding those
capabilities to your applications second
we're giving you the tools to build your
own models train them on your own
datasets and run those bottles on
Google's amazing infrastructure or
anywhere you want so let's start with
Google's fully trained pre-built models
we have a growing number of models that
have already been trained on Google's
with Google with its own domain
expertise and datasets and we've
packaged these days API is up so that
you can simply just drop them into your
application and these api's api is act
like of an intelligent component that
allows your application to understand
speech in photos translate text and
parsed natural languages and as I
mentioned these are the same models that
power many applications inside of
Google's such as Google Photos which
allows you to find a picture of almost
anything
Google safe search which moderates for
inappropriate content in Google
Translate which uses OCR to extract text
in multiple languages today we want to
talk to you about one more these api is
in a bit more detail the cloud video
intelligence API now the most prevalent
data on the Internet is video hundreds
of terabytes of digital video are being
generated every hour and understanding
the contents of that data has tremendous
commercial value I'm excited to invite
Lee onstage to show you the video
intelligence API in action League
[Music]
Thank You Brad I'm actually very excited
today to give this live demo because the
video intelligence API is one of the
api's that I really really love and the
reason for that is because I am NOT a
data scientist I'm a developer so I can
still make use of machine learning and
do all these fancy cool stuff the way
how it works it's a REST API so what I
do is I can upload a video in a bucket
and then the video intelligence API will
return me adjacent feet with labels of
everything that it can see so then think
about landmarks positions of faces
objects and it'll give that back with a
timestamp and also a confidence level
now let me give you a demo what you see
here is a video of the International
Women's Day and when I play it you see
there are lots of different shot changes
you see here all powerful women you see
women in politics women in sports you
see infants you see all kinds of shots
here now imagine that I would be like a
company and I would like to categorize
this video form from our website then I
would have to watch the full video and
then I need to write down all the labels
of everything that I can see now you can
imagine if I would link my I I probably
would miss the shot here and therefore
we let the machine do this that's what
we did here in this demo you can see
here all the labels that machine and
tell the Machine machine learning and
televideo intelligence saw so for
example I see here a football player and
you see it also returns like a time
frame there it is and here's a cartoon
that's pretty amazing I think it's also
the other way around so let's say that I
have like petabytes of video data and I
yeah let's say I write a blog post and I
want to with my blog post I would like
to show a video let's say I write a blog
post about basketball it's really nice
that the video intelligence API because
it labeled everything that I am mean
we can find all the videos that contain
basketball and do let me show you a demo
of that so here I have my video
application again and I search for
basketball let me um search for
basketball here and there you go
you see two videos in my whole full
video database that contains basketball
and as you can see the first video it
contains lots of shots of our basketball
and you see that it's on every key on
every keyframe but I actually also had
another video about basketball which
which was just like one single shot go
back there and I would have never known
that that also contains basketball so
with the video intelligence API it makes
you very easy to understand your video
library and with that said I'd like to
hand it over to Brett thank you very
much thanks Leigh thanks for the great
demo of course that's all great but what
about leveraging your own data sets for
artificial intelligence to achieve this
we give you the ability to train your
own data sets using Google clouds
machine learning engine cloud ml engine
helps you train your model using a
custom tensor flow graph for any ML use
case using CPUs or GPUs you can easily
train your model using tensor flow
focusing on the creativity of your
solution and leave the infrastructure to
us and when you're done you can publish
those models to make predictions for
your application using simple API calls
to put that training to use so tensor
flows is an important part of this so
what is tensor flow tensor flow is an
open source machine learning library
originally developed by Google and it's
used to create and train your machine
learning models and the uptake of
tension flow has been phenomenal tensor
flow is the most popular open source
machine learning project on github with
contributions coming from many companies
not just Google and in addition to being
a powerful framework tensorflow was
designed
to run anywhere you can run tensorflow
on our cloud ml engine as I just
described or you can run them on your
own servers in your own data centers or
anywhere you want like mobile devices
now in order to accelerate your business
this typically means building
applications and continuously improving
them to take advantage of your data the
insights you've derived as well as your
machine learning models this means
creating software to make important
long-term decisions and wells as well as
real-time decisions like what offered to
put in front of a customer before they
potentially leave your website now for
your applications you want to focus on
creating great software not managing
infrastructure and the key to being able
to create great software is to unleash
your developers from the burdens of
infrastructure today way too much
developer time is spent on configuring
and managing hardware and software
infrastructure
this results in your developers spending
their time as operators and not being
developers so at Google our goal is to
allow you to accelerate your software
management by making it easy for you to
build your applications at global scale
without needing to know about or
understand the infrastructure details
because at the end of the day you want
your developers to be writing code not
patching operating and scaling
infrastructure and that's what your
developers want - so in Google Cloud we
enable this by offering new server lists
and container solutions at scale with
different options to meet your different
needs this is provided by the three
services shown here container engine App
Engine and cloud functions container
engine is our fully managed kubernetes
as a service it's the fastest way to
take advantage of kubernetes and lets
you scale docker containers easily in
production and since Google started
kubernetes it's no accident that GCP
provides the easiest way to run Cooper
in the cloud Catina engine uses the same
open-source kubernetes codebase to
orchestrate your application allowing
you to easily leverage the rest of GCC
CP for running your service and
container engine handles all the
infrastructure details its schedules and
manages your containers automatically
letting you focus on your application
and as a proof point most of you will
probably remember Niantic use Catina
engine to launch their blockbuster
pokemon go game that game famously
scaled to many millions of users across
dozens of countries over a period of
days they reached a capacity in scale
that was 50 times yes 50 times their
pre-launch estimates so it's quite an
amazing launch and product now some
application developers don't even want
to think about clusters they want to
uplevel their focus even a notch higher
to what the industry is calling service
server list means that there is no
cluster no nodes no pods to think about
all you see when you implement deploy
and manage your application are
application level constructs in addition
another benefit of server list is at
when your application the application
consumes little or no resources when
there's zero load it could then quickly
start up and scale out as low demands it
in Google clouds App Engine pioneered
service lists serverless empowering
applications to scale from serene one
request a day to quickly scaling
millions of requests per second an app
engine manages everything on behalf
shown here you just add your application
code and this is really liberated the
developers add big companies like
snapchat Home Depot philips lightning
and other companies allowing them to
achieve incredible time to scale market
and agility now if you actually just
want to run some functions in the cloud
we have you covered there with cloud
functions we've cloud functions a
developer can connect
existing cloud services or build brand
new ones in entirely serverless way with
top functions you only pay for the
resources consumed while your functions
are running billing occurs at the
nearest 1/10 of a second and cloud
functions can be triggered by a growing
list of events generated by GCC services
essentially we've designed cloud
functions so it's easy to extend GCP to
fit your business needs in addition you
can use cloud functions from firebase as
well this makes it very easy for mobile
developers to add server-side extensions
without having to learn about configure
or deal with servers and there are many
use cases for cloud functions from the
triggering the triggering of examination
of files that have been recently
uploaded to your cloud storage to
triggering events that are in your logs
to reacting to actions your users are
taking in your applications
ok and with that I'm now pleased to
introduce Thomas to talk about how
dailymotion is using Google cloud to
improve and accelerate their services
amis thank you very much Brad
thank you very much hello everyone I am
Tamara I'm the vice president of data at
dailymotion today we're going to be
speaking of dead emotion of course and
also about the way that we use Google
cloud to power applications and what
difference it makes to us so the
demotion is one of the leading video
platforms in the world we have three
billion users three billion views and
300 million users per month on a catalog
of 150 million videos we have offices in
five continents and we are translated in
the 20 languages in terms of data we
receive 3.5 billion events per day but
more importantly recently we have been
through a complete overhaul of our
customer experience we have redesigned
every
from bottom to a two-floor and we have
relied heavily on machine learning to do
that we have of course developed classic
algorithms for trending videos popular
channels but we have also done more
special things like semantic annotation
which means that we try not only to
understand what objects we recognize in
a video but to understand what the topic
of the video is about an ontology of 25
million topics so for instance you can
see any video that we have on big corner
or jehoshua recently this is very
important to us because it helps us to
detect what are the trending topics at
the moment this helps our users to have
a topic based navigation to see more
videos on the same topic and it also
helps us to understand better what our
users are interested about we also host
the music content of universal music and
so we have also put in place neural nets
to analyze the music track of our music
videos so that they can put them in the
representation a vectorial
representation of what they contain and
they help us to build smart playlists to
help our our users discover more
interesting content that is related to
the current clips are watching now to
come back on GCP and how we use it for
us GCP is really helping us to increase
our speed obviously our speed of
development but also it helps us
building better products because it
allows us to have our data available to
our algorithms faster so on the first
point
on development time so our apps sent 3.5
billion events a day and we have
developed a pipeline that goes through
pub/sub data flow and bigquery in real
time in terms of development speed this
took us only two weeks to implement
because we could find on GCP all the
basic bricks that allowed us to set it
up but beyond the speed at which we have
developed this what matters even more is
that now whenever we are thinking about
a new product instead of trying to think
about okay what architecture are we
going to use what stack what
technologies are going to set up how are
going to maintain them the first
question we ask is can we do this with
SQL because bigquery is so fast that it
can leverage all the amount of data that
we send to it in a matter of seconds and
so it's fast enough for most of our
production applications and so with this
pipeline we are able to address issues
like how many concurrent users do you
have on a given live video we are able
to build very simple recommender
algorithms and we also provide real-time
analytics to the partners that approach
videos on the platform and it's really
helping us to go faster in our backlog
and to release more features for our
users so having the data available fast
can bring marginal improvements for some
algorithms like recommendation for some
other algorithms it is make or break for
instance we have recently developed a
new algorithm to detect fraudulent
impressions on the platform and we used
to base it on old adult pipelines that
took seven hours for data to be made
available to the algorithm when we
switch to the bigquery real-time
pipelines
we were able to intercept ten times more
ten times more fraudulent impressions
because we're more reactive and so to
summarize my message the acceleration
that the cloud provides us is real at
the emotion it impacts our development
speed and the quality of our products
and so for us it is an investment in
what our customers see thank you very
much Thank You Thomas
it's great to see the impressive results
that you've gained using our cloud and
I'd like to introduce Francois who
explain how the cloud is transforming in
the historic retail brand Francois juice
I want our lid dyskinetic remove Italian
Pedro dude on the doughnut rejection so
effective because let's not even not
whole crazy sauce icon sign don't touch
down zone Vivanco jovi no electricity
come on people don't get home as though
laponia
alien federal dude velasca come on sale
on this whistle concept mala selection
dolan a commercial innovation report a
telephone tacos Panos receive tomatoes
on a questionnaire Cosabella audit
recognize any distance Alva Naga do
tavad Iroquois servants like milky on
some question a sassy TMZ legend view
total I guess else promote women Connie
sellecca tailored levanta cause problems
in society like jay-z Nvidia dr. ejoute
try Clamato LeCompte I know that
Congress decided not sophisticated
Trigon the tripod suitable scale allow
you to scan more modest michelada water
let's recap America live a new tricycle
or disturb Chaka Khan hacer la doot
Selassie - Eric somepony seated on it
this is in Bern experience viscosity
Papa stability so hotel net of the
source on Terrance's Purcell residue
rule with Nutella company its
association l-mawla fragmovie radical
christian Iquitos Peru hey Cortana tell
Bella new coach of knowledge on my CV
yes Amulya
Veronica Di Canio a consequence for me
bozo viva la época comedy person
received a fair online wanna do same
shitty report on second D'Onofrio mr.
Nicastro disc Santuario de Chimayo
amazon of hands
merci beaucoup Mon mr. Candide existed
over Sabathia Papa woman I will tell him
at nada
thus confirming the other one on this
remote ownership that officer Avila said
Hornet telepaths Laveau dude Camino drop
is premature Adela data identity
management scenario would not the title
be a transformational delegate from at
the mother I observe Allah say the use
cases with a more a provisional more
that they develop a wizard Allah that
most excited or not opens this alert a
decrease in the on accessible via
satellite technology pasture the person
promoted Rosario Silla technology using
McChrystal verdict
it was aware the animala la coop
selection on all the debt that the
person is edged higher
descriptive data open space episode
credit of compulsive a space a
prospective say doc team is a no
decision Escalante is not a speck on our
evil counsel a professor laughs airily
democracy on platform module we do not
permit eye surgery per se seasons and a
part of telecom pluto on-premise have a
global data center don't police raided a
model platform
Picasa visit area transformation level
dude nullify the cloud dog led you to a
larger performers fetish it has reserved
a table afternoon the data don't Saladin
see a byung-soo city or historical
introduction advertised on the NCAA
necesita important all knew they were
our doctor now like that I don't son
again that does emphasis upon new secure
repair America direction to collect the
lead reporter Manawa Lucy develop a this
application fully develop a digital root
Odessa is a process it'll a platform
little person promote the module that
annek rotate the avaricious systems that
are say with two other disciplines
control very battery elude an appointed
a new voila new mentality developed a
program in a solar technology so develop
more dismissive of emotional control a
map no self respect ourselves it open
the civil support second affairs or
follow the travels arid area motors
committees on via civilian the madre a
lot this Remo up hi Kelly rujuta
the permeation our massacre said those
new low considered a rocker tune same at
no allow economy like that Asha Google
don't treat data warehouse pre do that I
mapped out my mother's new don't
considered a genre Tom the accessibility
does emphasis on physical now in pharma
deputies muscle ability to do zircon
effect on a montero Wikipedia the like
that avec dollar portions action
abdullah abdullah hashem vocal the
iCloud speech API Petra castle to
national musical ability to desert alone
now it build and appointed I'm a pop top
one more time the resulta
selectivity well now for our duty
Tippecanoe by more coming not wisdom a
technology to allow seasoned and
naturally little refine a lacuna
visual move what are some else my
contribution will ask us is as shown the
modular Google well as commercially pure
sadhana I miss here the cannot even in
wha-la Shella we do talk back to some
glare fluent come to Navy under sail you
know to annex knowledge you know I think
small role in a paper to come some fat
little chilly voila voila voila
fetching here on budget donated I'm
[Music]
sorry okay
thank you it's amazing to see such a
great transformation so quickly using
Google fountain okay
and now I'd like to thank you I've had
the privilege of being able to share
with you how Google cloud can accelerate
your business by helping effectively
manage your data drive intelligence from
your data and artificial intelligence to
your applications and how to accelerate
building and running those applications
and to talk about Google cloud as a
partner let me call on stage Sam Ramji
vice president of product management Sam
[Music]
hello everyone I hope you're doing great
it's an honor to be here today at Google
we believe that customers are looking
for something new a new kind of business
relationship a new suite of technologies
a new place to do things in a new way
and a partner with a new approach our
support of this new kind of partnership
starts with openness I'm going to focus
on two things first support for what you
want to run and for what you have to run
second flexible customer friendly
pricing it's about putting you in
control of your technology so our
customers are telling us that business
is demanding more innovation faster on a
smaller budget and somehow IT has to
deliver all this we believe that you can
support your existing workloads for less
money allowing you to innovate so at
Google we've learned that your freedom
to innovate requires not having to worry
about our costs that's what we do
internally that's why our innovation
velocity is so high we free developers
from worrying about the trappings of
infrastructure as well as simplifying
what it's going to cost so the first
step is understanding and planning your
migration we're seeing global CIOs
migrating from their data centers to
save costs but their many benefits
beyond cost better security better
reliability and access to some amazing
innovations that live inside of Google
cloud ideally you want to migrate while
changing as little as possible you want
to minimize the change so that you
minimize the chance of breaking your
applications now later you'll refactor
to use managed services like cloud
spanner or our machine learning or the
DLP API so you want to migrate then
modernize our job is to make this easy
with both technology and people so you
probably know that Google cloud is a
great place for Linux and open source
development we're making it a great
place for windows developers and IT pros
as well we have support for people
images of many versions of Windows
Server as well as sequel server we also
support Active Directory in the cloud so
that you can extend your on-premises
Active Directory domain controllers
for developers our goal is to meet them
where they are without requiring
significant change so you can use Visual
Studio to deploy Net Applications and
manage cloud resources we've also
created hundreds of powershell
commandlets in the cloud SDK for
administrating your cloud projects to
help with your journey we also have an
amazing set of engineers when I think
about Google Cloud I think about our
engineer to engineer relationship first
our sales engineers in our solution
architects will help you understand
Google Cloud and get quickly get on to
getting your applications deployed our
support teams are backed by our product
engineering organization in case you
need help o guro talked to earlier she's
from the office of the CTO they work
directly with customers who are taking
on massive efforts that require industry
expertise in areas like manufacturing
energy healthcare or financial services
we have customer reliability engineers
who use Google's best practices for
creating billion users scale
applications and keeping them running
like Gmail search and adds they'll help
your team ensure reliability even in the
most extreme conditions and because we'd
participate directly in open source
communities we can often help you with
your questions or your issues in
deploying open source stacks whether on
premises or in Google cloud so this is
how we helped Evernote migrate their
entire software infrastructure from
on-premises to Google cloud in just 89
days so you might ask what's the best
test for minimal friction when migrating
I think the best test is zero downtime
it may sound impossible but we did it
work closely with Evernote working
engineer to engineer 200 million of
their customers moved to Google cloud
with no change in service and no
downtime Losh is another great example
in 22 days we moved 17 websites and
applications including core databases
users orders products and content
these are mission-critical they move
databases with sizes ranging from a few
gigabytes 200 gigabytes to Google cloud
and our engineer to engineer approach
made the migration process fast and
predictable
you dump data into cloud storage and
restore it into cloud sequel you shift
from a vertical scaling to a horizontal
scaling architecture to get there let's
talk about costs so clouds are supposed
to be elastic and free you from capex
and from capacity planning now some
cloud providers force you to pay upfront
for a three-year commitment in order to
get the best price but if you have to
buy a virtual machine for three years
how is that actually better than buying
your own server for three years we think
it's not a recent state of the clouds
report showed that cloud users waste 45
percent of their bill on resources we
don't use now that waste is caused by
many factors first three year leases
force you to predict your future
perfectly and really none of us are
capable of doing that so you end up with
stranded resources second
just like with on-premises servers
you're forced to buy fixed machine
configurations with particular amounts
of RAM storage and CPU so you end up
paying for machine overtime that is too
big for you and some dimensions and too
small and others and you pay for the
full hour even if your test only takes
10 minutes so you're paying for compute
time that you're not using this all adds
up to 45% unnecessary expenditure we
think that there's a better and cheaper
way to run your cloud we believe that
we've solved all three of these sources
of waste in fact so first automatic
sustained use discounts that are applied
to give you saving this without any
long-term agreement as soon as you use a
VM for more than a week you will see
savings if you use a VM for an entire
month you will get a 30% discount which
are still free to stop using that VM at
any time sustained use discounts as we
like to say bring the cloud back in the
cloud change your mind at any time and
still get great prices it should be on
demand second you don't need to accept
to fixed machine configurations as we
say why would you want to have only
virtual machines whose shape comes in
powers of two with other providers if
your applications need 20 cores and
maybe 50 gigs of RAM you might have to
buy a 40 core 160 gigabyte machine you
could literally be paying for more than
double the resources you need
but with Google custom machines let you
dial in exactly the configuration you
need you pay for exactly the resources
that you use these are so popular that
over 20% of all the core hours operating
on Google cloud our custom machines
they're so popular what we decided to do
is help you save more money with our
right sizing recommendations so we apply
ml algorithms internally and prompt you
with alerts where we think that you
could save money because you're mean and
even your peak utilization of that
machine is lower than what you've
specified for the machine so we try to
suggest the best virtual machine size to
proactively save you money so finally
and this is pretty exciting pay only for
what she used by the seconds so Google
is the first to offer perf second
billing for all services you use a VM
for 90 seconds you pay for 90 seconds
this is available in active in Google
cloud today right now so Google cloud is
elastic you only buy what you need only
when you use it and you automatically
get discounts for sustained usage we
think this makes it much more simple for
you
we even alert you when you appear to be
wasting resources when you put all of
this together we save our customers on
an average 60% relative to what they pay
on other clouds with that it's my great
pleasure to introduce Christoph DeFeo
from Amadeus to talk about his
experience of this new kind of
relationship stuff
I'll chew some thank you very much thank
you thank you a lot of what some mansion
or isn't it to me because we we do use
many of the future invention
so now let's transition smoothly back to
friends my sides will be in English but
vapor if Kasich who can si Genesis have
10 more verbal gamma samosa doctors the
music may conceive who i'm alois nachos
do cloud poland you still travel no
Isaac speaking I'm Eddie was a little
mundial do not distribute have a low the
patron Tom you serve only company area
and lives across the way
I found the delivery the major service
of inertia nunca se was explicated Sam
we can say I'm a douche but at
Baskerville abilities enormous service
to little con el avión de servian be a
caboose action we are convinced on
barking Linda near the Boomer keep
readin Millia the passage II don't even
remember G Sal present to the count
passage epochs even imagining a mentos
onto another vastrel disobedience are
present to the system the chief until it
was actually cat million actual but we
also work to traffic also the digital
console transaction possible my key
element id' of Catco possible search
inertia to knowledge adopted scaleable
residual are a food a office avec des
services more massive Donna already
Kathmandu pedometers Samael developer
almond if we are sure no presents no Sun
Catalan GP imagine a socket wrench be
the Casino de Foix presents the
Macdonald almonds
they pop wanna do such a nervously don't
cloud outfits Elizabeth the way a
journalistic Anthony
I've only don't see nothin to voyage
progress ambient yet no decision of the
way I know that not do J no destination
to TT did I fix it on Odette a cotton
are either on Olympic officials did not
do see a vector a jonvoyage man on
constant include additional CDT you will
only my family as if a supermoon web
even Buddha CDR as a lambda W on if a
man also monitor Sosa tablets Osama
below I don't producer on a path a path
shown no Petra capital with imagine a
list rescue SMS holy system design
whatever the company iron via Gilchrist
Anyanka Rojas to do convection on her in
wash authority did this really due to
the mill for a tsunami effect coke Monte
tourism samosa
to no result of that c'mon kappa to
nealandsharon sarcasm oh and phillips
Calcott to diesel a don't add kept up
the consumption of castruccio
suppose i constantly in solution message
for cloud responsible
dupa dimitra's Amadou service team
massive mo those insights from the
platform as-a-service key supply module
called services here adapters room
Avenue scale services funky bass I saw
dr. kubernetes openshift LC adapter soon
Donato
well application the calculus Fatima
news Claire availability sassy on
average the opposite application
download download on a cloud I reckon
scalability Anthony on it one kappa
people are adamant the Voyager tutorial
dunno in precision a chasm of the sample
song again a silcoon over on that
nautical rectum on I wanted some whole
new companion
Rondo diploma recipe which is Google
cloud platform it is a repetition resume
hub as Europe as a marriage simple
Medawar it enlightens the minimum a on a
DeMille visibly deeply gasps Europe
skied on Terrace on sick arrogance led
from Kamsa in una Foucault Cal
communities poop Montella capacity hula
radial function element may come on
Google Alesia Musa didn't set the match
dry possible mode partials on moonlight
le premier it easily from Sibyl vane on
production on company responsible via
medic the virtual machine stoner on RLC
so the Primeau disappear optimism oku le
rideau sank on polonium duper like the
platform new paradigm of dynamic molar
capacity our oxygen which is on the
manager sons group eyes on the Google
machine longboarders Toscana Bosma a
virtual machine has Google no hoddan
injector machine exactly I don't see
where our own which is on Cuba in test
for deployment knows application
kubernetes open source don't kilometers
can be photo upstream your family
performance data platform son to an evil
curses were grass or substances from
canoes on proposed algorithm will
Nouveau deployment asked us to talk to
Google fairly reasonably modesty of sky
legged Intel
I mean you already performance a final
modest women on public soon rapid from
it takes Tomas table to swagger has
submitted another house with you where I
thought resistance of Pandora precursor
well the into topics we denote wires
don't clad men a coup de lluvias Tonko
aqui merci beaucoup
[Applause]
so to close out the morning let me
invite Sebastian Mahad to come back to
stage merci beaucoup massive attention
on sale approaches keynote become a
citizen show mercy of a maximum passing
clip who nucleon Francois to my
Christopher Prabhu baptised experience
seconds it has experienced pesky
mosquitoes in new comer medusa digital
Voyager a enables one the whole
experience on a besoin de cádiz iran
Avram opt [ __ ] a Doozer Naraku Metro
Moses is a polymerase Voyager electron
to Symmetra on Arab on the lap of the
day you know again is the less we do
sejuani
Oh totally a SQL Freeman single profit
you maximum this is a Juliet technique
classical technique over why agnostic
spare it stood on the presentation
probably in phone code the whole
experience is con una a daughter
well show to a Toshiba good Tonopah also
seek a digital comedy when I was reading
excellent John Amos inverted ASEAN
[Applause]